zuvor wollen wir aber Uwe John mit in
die Sendung nehmen den
Politikwissenschaftler da ist der Tag
der John aus Berlin zugeschaltet reden
wir zunächst mal über diesen Komplex
Union
/ und die anderen Parteien und die
rechtsaußenpartei AFD die ja in aller
Munde ist in diesen Tagen sagen Sie mal
Herr John gab es so etwas schon mal in
der Parteiengeschichte in Deutschland
das eine Partei quasi nichts tut nichts
konstruktives unternimmt und trotzdem
solch ein Höhe Flug erlebt
guten Tag Herr wittkau das ist
tatsächlich in der Tat ungewöhnlich das
liegt natürlich daran dass die AFD im
Moment die Protestwähler sehr stark
anzieht wir haben eine große
regierungsunzufriedenheit und die AFD
profitiert davon die Union eben nicht
obwohl sie ja die größere
parlamentarische Oppositionspartei ist
und deswegen versucht man dann in der
Union das ein oder andere Mal auch mehr
Profit davon zu schlagen und
herauszuholen und auch stärker zu
erscheinen und deswegen spricht man dann
auch über die AFD in der Union manchmal
etwas unbedacht wie Herr märz das dann
auch am Sonntag getan hat ich würde
gerne da noch mal nachfragen wollen wenn
Sie gestatten also nehmen wir mal also
die Frage warum wie viele Wähler denn
eventuell eventuell zu AFD laufen wir
reden ja immer noch von Umfragen nicht
von ergebnisen jetzt liegt die AFD
beispielsweise was Bayern angeht im
Moment bei
13%, was glauben Sie wie viel von diesen
13% ist denn jetzt sozusagen Protest von
Bürgerinnen und Bürger gegen die Politik
meinetwegen in Berlin und wie viel ist
reale Substanz von AFD Potenzial
wir können sagen dass etwa derzeit so
gut die Hälfte die AFD aus Überzeugung
fehlt das heißt weil sie mit den
programmatischen Entwürfen der Partei
einverstanden sind mit dem Auftreten der
Partei weil sie insbesondere in der
Migrationspolitik mit der AFD
übereinstimmen und die anderen also das
sind so 30 bis 40 Prozent die sind aus
Protest im Moment bei der AFD die wollen
der Politik in Berlin an den Denkzettel
verpassen auch zum Teil der Union und
deswegen sind die derzeit bei der AFD so
würde man ungefähr im Moment die
Verteilung einsetzen aber das würde doch
ich sag jetzt meinen Anführungsstrichen
die Erfolge der AFD in den Umfragen
durchaus relativieren das müsste doch
eigentlich auch den Schrecken für den
CDU-Vorsitzenden März nehmen oder
naja es ist halt so dass die CDU halt
überhaupt nicht profitiert und das
ärgert sie natürlich und sie versteht
das auch nicht dass sie gar nicht
profitiert denn sie ist ja nun mal die
größte Oppositionspartei und sie
stagniert im Moment bei so um die 30
Prozent 28 29 30 Prozent und kommt nicht
so richtig voran und natürlich überlegt
man woran liegt das und was können wir
besser machen was können wir anders
machen um tatsächlich hier voranzukommen
und deswegen thematisiert man oder
thematisiert Friedrich Merz dann
gelegentlich auch die AFD jetzt sagen
Sie er macht das möglicherweise auf die
falsche Art und Weise möglicherweise
unbedacht so wie er da spricht was die
Kooperation auf der kommunalen Ebene mit
der AFD angeht hat ja ihre quasi nur den
Stand der Dinge wiedergegeben und ist
beleibe ja auch nicht nur die CDU die da
Kommunalwahl mit der AFD irgendwie
kooperiert auf irgendeiner Art und Weise
die Kollegen von der Zeit haben das mal
ausgerechnet in 40 Fällen gab es solche
Kooperationen was macht denn März da
macht er die AFD auf die Art und Weise
noch stärker indem er über den Elefanten
leben im Raum spricht was macht er mit
diesem vielleicht unbedachten Äußerungen
in der Tat er hat die Folgewirkungen
wahrscheinlich nicht richtig
eingeschätzt der kommt aus einer
Generation von Politikern die eben noch
nicht so stark jedes Wort auf die
Goldwaage legen mussten als er eben noch
Fraktionsvorsitzender ein früheren
Zeiten war und jetzt sieht er halt dass
jedes Wort von ihm dann interpretiert
wird und dann eben auch in Richtung
interpretiert wird die dann
möglicherweise der AFD insofern nutzt
als nur als wir wieder über sie sprechen
und damit ihr mehr Aufmerksamkeit
zukommt und das ist etwas was eben dann
der AFD insofern nutzt als die
Aufmerksamkeit da die dabei ihr liegt
und viele Wählerinnen und Wähler dann
zur Kenntnis nehmen das ist offenkundig
für die CDU ein großes Problem darstellt
dass die AFD so stark geworden ist und
allein diese Aufmerksamkeit führt dann
dazu dass man sich ihr mehr zuwendet
jetzt hat also Friedrich Merz am
Wochenende in dem ZDF sommerinterview
das zur AFD gesagt was er gesagt hat
daraufhin war ja die Aufregung bei der
CDU einigermaßen enorm ich glaube kaum
vorher ist mal ein CDU-Vorsitzender
derart gebächt worden und vor allem aus
unterschiedlichen richt ungen gepäscht
worden was heißt das für Friedrich Merz
in dieser Situation
das heißt eben eher man verlangt von ihm
von vielen Seiten dass er in klaren Kurs
bestimmt er hat ja jetzt noch mal dann
auch nachgebessert in Anführungszeichen
gesetzt indem er gesagt hat ja
selbstverständlich wird es keine aktive
Kooperation mit der AFD geben dass ist
ja auch parteitagsbeschlusslage und
daran würde er sich halten aber er muss
eben erkennen das ist auch Kritiker in
der Partei gibt die eben jetzt von ihm
eine klare Linie verlangen und dass er
die Partei auf eine einheitliche Linie
einführt das ist etwas was eben seine
Kritiker ihm entgegenhalten und übrigens
ja so massiv wie die Kritik jetzt
derzeit ist das musste Angela Merkel
damals in der Migrationsfrage auch zum
Teil erleben das ist also nicht völlig
ungewöhnlich für ein CDU-Vorsitzenden
Frau Merkel hat das damals mit dem
Abtritt quittiert vom cdu-parteivorsitzt
so weit würde ich glaube ich Friedrich
Merz nicht einschätzen dass er so weit
gehen müsste denn er ist ja der erste
von den Mitgliedern direkt und mit
überwältigender Mehrheit gewählte aber
man verlangt jetzt von ihm und das
Verlangen eben auch viele Gliederungen
von ihm und viele PolitikerInnen in
Spitzen Position dass er eine klare und
einheitliche Linie vertritt und dass sie
nicht immer wieder diese manchmal etwas
unangebrachten Sätze oder Worte
entlocken dass er sich die nicht
entlocken lässt denn es ist ja nicht das
erste Mal das Friedrich Merz hier man
kann sagen in eine rhetorische Falle
getappt ist und immer mal wieder eben
mit solchen provokanten Äußerungen dann
eben eine entsprechende Gegenreaktion
auslöst ja Herr Professor John
vielleicht ist auch der Unterschied
zwischen März und Merkel der dass Frau
Merkel ja im Kanzleramt saß immer noch
und die Politik gestalten musste und
konnte und Friedrich Merz ist ja nur in
Anführungsstrichen der Oppositionsführer
da kommen wir vielleicht mal auf Markus
Söder wir sind ja das Livebild hier im
Hintergrund wir warten ja auf die
Pressekonferenz aus Bayreuth dieser
Außentermin des Kabinetts im Beisein von
Ursula von der Leyen also das ist neue
Schloss was wir da im Hintergrund sehen
zu bayreut dass du soll vermutlich
schöne Bilder noch einmal Skifahren
bevor es in Bayern in die politische
Sommerpause geht Bayern ist ja im Grunde
genommen schon fast im heißen Wahlkampf
angelangt Anfang Oktober wird dort
gewählt Söder hat gestern der
CDU-Vorsitzender der CSU-Vorsitzender in
der Pressekonferenz sich sehr deutlich
abgegrenzt von irgendwelchen
Überlegungen von wegen kommunal
Zusammenarbeit Kooperation mit der AFD
könnte es sein dass Markus Söder da
jetzt sozusagen indirekt wenn man so ein
bisschen in die Zukunft schaut ans Jahr
2025 und die kanzlerkandidatenfrage
denkt dass er möglicherweise davon
profitieren wird können
auszuschließen ist das nicht aber Markus
Söder muss erst zunächst mal ein
fulminanten Wahlsieg Einfahren in Bayern
um überhaupt wieder als Kanzlerkandidat
in Frage zu kommen also steht ihm schon
eine schwere Aufgabe bevor im Oktober
und anschließend muss man sagen er muss
das Vertrauen der CDU zurückgewinnen
denn durch die Beschädigungen des
Kanzlerkandidaten Armin Laschet im Jahr
2021 hat er in der CDU doch einiges an
Vertrauen verspielt viele sind ihnen
deswegen immer noch nicht grün und da
muss Markus Söder müsste noch viel
arbeiten um eben dieses Vertrauen bei
den CDU-Mitgliedern und gerade bei den
führungsleuten der CDU zurückzugewinnen
ja Söder muss erstmal ein
fulminatenweissieg einfallen das wird
gar nicht so einfach werden Herr
Professor jung ich habe die Zahlen
vorlegen
38,8 % in der aktuellen Sonntagsfrage
für Bayern wenn er am Ende des Tages so
ein Ergebnis einfahren würde könnte er
zufrieden sein aber wer weiß wie gesagt
AFD 13% zur Zeit in Bayern niemand weiß
ob sich das nicht noch nach oben
entwickeln wird
vielleicht bleiben wir noch mal einen
Moment bei Markus Söder und seiner CSU
das will ja immer die Stimme der
bayerischen Politik in Berlin sein mit
Alexander Dobrind der ist ja der Chef
der Landesgruppe welchen Eindruck haben
sie seitdem die CSU auch dass der
Bundesregierung raus ist mit dem
Regierungswechsel hat den Bayern
wirklich ja eine mächtige Sprache
mächtiges Stimmrecht in Berlin in diesen
Zeiten
na Markus Söder fährt wieder die alte
Bekannte bayern-strategie so würde ich
es mal nennen die auch das
Überlebensprinzip der CSU lange Zeit war
zumindest die Mehrheitsfähigkeit
betreffend nämlich dass die bayerische
Landesregierung Gegenpositionen zur
Bundesregierung bezieht das fällt ihm
jetzt besonders leicht in diesen Tagen
weil eben hier die CSU an der Regierung
nicht beteiligt ist und er deswegen an
vielen Stellen die Bundesregierung die
drei Ampel koalitions die drei Ampel
Koalitionsparteien in wesentlicherweise
und manchmal auch in deutlicher Mania
kritisieren kann das ist etwas was
typisch eigentlich für die CSU
Landesregierung in Bayern ist und da
kommt ihm diese Konstellation entgegen
auch kommt ihm entgegen das im Moment
das Verhältnis zwischen CSU und CDU ganz
gut ist und dass man nicht von großen
Keile rein oder Streitereien zwischen
den beiden Schwester Parteien hört
Markus Söder hat gestern nach einer
Sitzung des CSU Vorstandes auch eine
Pressekonferenz gegeben und er und der
Innenminister Joachim Herrmann und
Manfred Weber und auch Alexander
drobrind haben sehr stark auf die
Migrationsfrage abgehoben a in Bayern
aber B auch deutschlandweit und reden
zum Beispiel darüber dass sie Leistungen
für abgelehnte Asylbewerber im
europaweiten Vergleich in Deutschland
besonders groß sind besonders hoch sind
und wollen da Dinge verändern haben Sie
den Eindruck in Berlin dass dieses
migrationsthema von der Ampel wirklich
so gesehen wird als das was es im Land
gesehen wird nämlich als riesiges als
drängendes Problem
es gibt halt unterschiedliche
Positionierungen und die Mehrheit der
Bevölkerungen stimmt immer in der Regel
eher restriktiveren Lösungen zu zumal
auch die
cdu/csu-potentiellen Wählergruppen
insofern muss man sagen dass hier eben
unterschiedliche Positionen
aufeinanderprallen und hier die cdu/csu
eben deutlich restriktivere Lösungen
favorisiert ist ja nicht nur die CSU
sondern auch die CDU deren
parlamentarischer Geschäftsführer freier
vor kurzem auch Einschränkungen
vorgeschlagen hat hier muss man also
deutlich sehen dass die Mehrheit der
Bevölkerung in in den größten meisten
Fällen eher für restriktive ihre
Lösungen Eintritt und das CDU und CSU
hier zumal den
merkelkurs nicht mehr favorisieren
sondern sich von diesem abkehren es
dürfte die größte Abkehr der
Unionsparteien sein vom Merkel Kurs an
dieser Stelle und wie gesagt sie trifft
auf eine relativ breite Zustimmung in
großen Teilen ihrer potentiellen
Wählerschaft das Thema insgesamt eignet
sich sehr stark zur Polarisierung und
deswegen ist es auch immer ein schmaler
Grad für die Unionsparteien weil eben
hier
die AFD ja auch versucht dieses Thema
für sich erfolgreich zu nutzen Professor
John vielen Dank bis hierher